[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video bring you the
fate of jamie-lynns during the final
season supported leagues trailer teasers
promotional photos and a few theories
and predictions of mine Jimmy will
rarely delaine's to forces in the
Riverlands and set a totally free in
Episode one he will arrive at lynnster
in Riverland for system NFL in Episode
two and he'll reunite with quite a bit
of characters like Tyrion bran and bran
Stark in Episode three Jimmy will fight
in the battle for Winterfell and thanks
to the official Russian translated
trailer we now know who's name is Jamie
shouting in his clip Jamie will say
brains life and by my theory he will
also kill his sister Cersei and possibly
even kill the night King thereby truly
earning the name Kingslayer with all
that being said let's just jump in it
starting with a quick recap about Jaime
sir Jaime Lannister is the eldest son of
timing younger twin brother of Cersei
and told her brother of the eternal
lannister he was involved in an
incestuous relationship with Cersei and
he is a biological father of her three
children
Joffrey Marcel and Tommen Jaime
previously served in the Kingsguard a
very stag Aryan known as the Mad King
before infamously backstabbing him
during the sack of King's Landing
earning Jaime the nickname of the
Kingslayer he continued to serve in the
Kingsguard of Robert Baratheon and as a
lord commander for Roberts alleged sons
Joffrey and Tommen
however are confrontation with the faith
of the seven led to his dismissal from
the sword order bits Ursus accession to
the Iron Throne and in the light of the
death of their uncle circum Lannister
Jimmy was appointed as the new commander
of the Lannister armies however he left
his position to honour and help the
north face the White Walkers after he
learned that certain young graduate
plots honor the truce between the Iron
Throne and the alliance of House
Targaryen and House Stark Jaime
Lannister's arrival at Winterfell was
firstly teased by the official season 8
photos where we saw Jamie in a stark
armor that by the way looks exactly like
Rob's sitting in a room dead the judging
by the type of the wall in the
background seems to be located at
Winterfell
and then the trailer confirmed it Jaime
will indeed arrive at Winterfell likely
in episode 1 ending or episode 2
beginning and he will also fight for NFL
against the night king in his army he
cannot help much without an arm
but it's not a problem since Jamie will
get himself one along the way the first
we'll see of Jamie Lannister in season 8
in my opinion will be at the crossroad
scene where he'll make a stop for the
night
that's also the place where Bronn will
finally catch up with Jamie and where
the two will reunite the next morning
the two won't continue traveling the
Kings Road that ran straight towards
Winterfell
but instead will take on the River Road
that runs west into the Riverlands Jaime
and Bronn will go to Riverrun to rally
the lynnster forces they were sent to
the Riverlands to ensure peace and while
added Jaime will probably set a new
tally free under one condition
to rally the Riverlands and March the
north at once to help his nieces and
nephews defend Winterfell against the
night king just recently the cast lineup
for the game - on season 8 premiere was
leaked visible for all to see on HBO
schedule and the name of an actor who
plays the North alley was there and in
my opinion it confirms that Jaime will
pay him a visit in season 8 premiere set
him free and convince him to go with him
to Winterfell then either at the end of
episode 1 or at the beginning of episode
2
Jaime will finally arrive in a velvet
brown by his side and the Lannister
forces that he managed together as well
as the dead mirror and the Riverlands
forces he managed to rally Jaime will
have a huge renew made quite a bit of
characters
Tyrion Imbrium will be proud that Jamie
is on his pledge
well then in sense I will be a bit
suspicious about his intention upon
finding out that Cersei betrayed him the
last king why did he come to Winterfell
with little Ensor forces and why did it
rarely the Riverland sweet Admiral and
his beloved sister and lover is
obviously not going to help them and why
should they even trust him that's when
Jamie's line from the official trailer
will come out he will reply with I
promise to fight for living and I intend
to keep that promise
of course Jamie's most important reunion
is the one with bran stark a kid he
tried to kill to keep from reporting
what he had witnessed which if he had
reported would have ended with Jaime
Cersei and all of their children being
executed obviously we don't expect from
Starks to execute Jaime
after all Johnston and then invited the
Lancers to come and support the living
in the worlds to come Jaime agreed an
honours pledge meaning that no harm
would Jon do to him nor would he allow
anyone else to do so
meaning that Arya most likely will not
kill Jaime as soon as she finds out
Jaime attempted to kill her sibling bran
stark will likely forgive Jaime and this
one will say brings life in episode 3
during the
battle for Winterfell which has actually
been hinted by the official trailer if
you have seen the trailer you notice
that Jamie's panicking in this clip and
he shouts something but you cannot
really say for sure what exactly is he
shouting however the official Russian
translated trailer gave us an answer to
that Jamie clearly shouts the name of
brain stark I cannot play that clip here
because of copyright issues but I'll
leave the link to the trailer and exact
time it happens check it out and you'll
see for yourself that Jamie's clearly
shouting the name of brain so what
happens is that Jamie probably sees a
bunch of ice bridging the crypts of NFL
or the guts would open our file wherever
brain is at that moment Jamie sees it
and so he shouts brain to someone likely
Arya as a warning that his life is in
danger then Jamie and Arya probably run
to defend brain so Jamie now I go for
brain who is probably accompanied by Sam
wherever they are and this right here
might be Arya and behind her Jamie's Sam
pushing brain as they all run for
something
Sanjay means same girl pushing brain in
his wheelchair will not be as quick as
Arya she'll try to distract at something
random running get away and a
face-saving brain and this is the clip
of her doing it and here we can actually
see what's chasing her in this slide
inversion if you look closely you notice
that she looks to be pursued by
something with a skeletal face keep it
in mind that Arya does not fear death
she'd stand and fight anyone or anything
or it would not be afraid of whites or
white walkers as she's actually fighting
those in the trailer she would not run
from them especially since she's holding
a knife made of jus which kills them I
think the one chasing her or least one
among the mr. Broderick on who died at
the battle the bastards who's been
buried in the crypts below of NFL Aria
season the tricking she cries and is not
able to fight him so she runs back to
Jamie so he comes to Winterfell with all
the forces he managed together gives his
best during the battle when he fell and
saves bran nothing less have expected
for Jamie he is doing what's right and
he's finally being himself truly
honorable man an actor who plays Jamie
Nikolaj coster-waldau tease that it's
exactly what Jamie will do throughout
the final season he said the Jamie's
choosing to do what he believes is right
fighting for the good side and and bad
earning sources right but giving Cersei
in season 8 episode 5 upon he finds out
she plans to burn the entire capital to
the ground by using wildfire including 1
million innocent people as well as John
Denny there
armies will come there after the fall of
NFL and I'll be fighting the night King
and his arm inside would also be the
right choice that's one end game theory
for Jamie let's talk about it for a
minute even though the living side will
suffer a tremendous defeat them NFL most
of the main characters will make it out
alive including Jamie Lannister the
entire living side will have to seek
refuge summer south and as it's been
confirmed by leaked photos John and
Danny will come to King's Landing to
once again parley with Cersei at the end
of season seven search his plan was to
LA for enemies to exhaust themselves
against the army of the Dead then he had
the gun company mop up the remnants so
whoever is left in the north however the
army of the Dead is the one that will
win the battle for the north this is a
moment Cersei will forge a new plan she
will now allow the entire living side to
seek refuge at the capital but she will
also open the city gates for the army of
the Dead Cersei's plan is to have all of
them fighting inside King's Landing
whereupon she would burn them all with
wildfire that is hidden all over the
capital and that they get rid of all our
enemies at first glance it would seem
like John is coming to plead versus help
after the living side has suffered a
huge loss is a benefit after all John
would now return to enemy territory
unless the circumstances were dire and
that's exactly what's happening here
long story short this huge meeting
between Cersei and John will end with
another fake promise son sources behalf
she will ensure John the living side can
seek refuge in King's Landing and it
must not fall while she's actually
setting already mentioned trap when
Jamie finds out that Cersei intends to
use wildfire to get rid of father
enemies including chance and then his
armies that came to save the capital
Jaime will realize his sister is no
different than a Mad King when Jamie
finds out the church is about to order
the entire city to be burned down to
ashes with 1 million people rather than
support living side and fight the night
King because she knows that the living
side is to win she'll not be able to
keep the ar.drone
Jaime will have to do something huge
Jaime will have to kill his sister Jaime
already sacrificed his honor once in
order to save hundreds of thousands of
innocent lives by killing the Mad King
and has ever since been called the
Kingslayer however Cersei now intends to
do the same it's pretty safe to say that
Jaime is going to kill his sister once
she gives an order to Qyburn - as the
Mad King used to say burn them all Jaime
will do noble sacrifice once again but
this time he will not trade it with his
honor this time it requires
life Jamie will sacrifice himself by
killing Cersei as he knows the mountain
will kill him immediately that's one end
game theory for Jaime the other states
that Jaime will actually kill the knight
King thereby truly earning the name
Kings later all his life it's been an
insult but now people will cone that in
triumph this time everyone will know
that Jaime Lannister is the savior of
Westeros and the only reason they're
alive
that's a Jaime the night Kingslayer
Lannister and game theory perhaps he'll
kill both Circe and night king but I
highly doubt it I do however believe
that he'll kill one of them although
it's probably going to be Cersei
Lannister there here guys Jamie's fate
in season 8 with some events being
confirmed and the other just predictions
saying theories of mine
in conclusion Jaime will definitely play
a huge role in this final season and one
cannot simply wait to see how Jamie's
story will play out feel free to leave
your thoughts about all this in the
comment section down below do you like
this Jaime's path through season 8 and
his endgame theorists or do not and if
you think I missed something please let
me know and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace